get ready to move the latest version of  baby shark is expected to be a hit  and may the force be with parents trying  to get this star wars toy  the child is definitely one of those big  hot items this year  the child aka baby yoda now comes in a  remote control version  and they can use that to control all of  the child's movements you can make him  walk you can play hide and seek with him  experts say parents seeking a hot toy  don't want to wait too  long the pandemic has more people buying  online which could lead to shipping  delays  naomi rockham cbs news new york  i know what i'm getting alex for the  holidays if you give beauty a baby shark  toy i will hurt you it did cross my mind  4 44. coming up on good day las vegas  we'll sort this out in the commercial  while you  watch